et vulnérables tout ceci justifie donc
que nous restions très vigilants le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
va vous présenter le dispositif de
surveillance qui est mis en place pour
tous les départements et qui permet
partout sur le territoire de prendre des
mesures de précaution si nécessaire tous
les départements vont bénéficier de
nouvelles mesures fortes de
déconfinement mais nous allons
surveiller avec une vigilance
particulière les départements
d'ile-de-france la guyane et mayotte
dans ces départements le site le virus
circule un peu plus qu'ailleurs et des
inquiétudes spécifiques demeure donc le
ministre de la santé il reviendra dans
ces départements
nous allons qualifié de départements en
orange le déconfinement sera dans les
trois semaines qui viennent un peu plus
prudent que sur le reste du territoire
au cours de cette phase 2 et je veux
insister sur cet élément qui est
important la liberté enfin va redevenir
la règle et l'interdiction constituera
l'exception nous avons ainsi notamment
décider l'accélération de la réouverture
des écoles et collèges dans toutes les
zones et des lycées dans les
départements vers le ministre de
l'éducation du national il reviendra
dans un instant la réouverture des cafés
des restaurants des bars le retour
progressif de la vie culturelle et
sportive avec des contraintes
spécifiques dans les zones de vigilance
orange
la réouverture des parcs et jardins en
zone orange
mais cette liberté retrouvée implique
des contraintes qui sont en quelque
sorte des contreparties la limitation
des regroupements à 10 personnes dans
l'espace public est maintenu le principe
du recours au télétravail doit toujours
être privilégiés on le comprend bien le
respect des gestes barrières surtout
doit rester très rigoureux et le port du
masque est maintenant largement
recommandée par les autorités sanitaires
nous continuerons et j'en suis désolé
mais c'est mon devoir a limité les
formes de la vie sociale les plus
propices à la transmission du virus les
sports de contact
les boîtes de nuit les regroupements de
très large public en particulier le
ministre le dira il faut éviter les
rassemblements de personnes dans les
lieux couverts et sans organisation
adaptée
enfin il faut continuer de veiller aux
personnes vulnérables et leur demander
de poursuivre leurs efforts pour se
protéger vous